one of the students looked at me as he
walked by and said you are going to
freak out
which is usually a good a good thing to
hear before one of these meetings
hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show where in this video i had the
pleasure to interview
david lu professor at harvard university
the broad institute and howard hughes
medical institute
david's lab is using chemistry and
evolution to develop
next-generation therapeutics they've
developed base editors and prime editors
to study and hopefully treat different
genetic disorders
from his work david has co-founded many
different
biotechnology companies including editas
medicine pairwise plants
and beam therapeutics so i hope you
enjoyed the following interview
but first i need to de-animate not
deaminate
as we'll learn about later hmm what does
this do
so hi david thank you so much for
joining me today um and welcome to the
cheeky science show you are officially
the first ever guest and i'm
particularly excited because
it was probably the first video that did
quite well for me in my channel was all
about
prime editing which is a gene editing
technique that was developed in your lab
which we'll come on to a bit later and
so it feels like i've kind of gone full
circle about here
so it's just great to have you on oh
well i'm i'm uh really honored
to be your first guest and i'm a big fan
of your videos and your channel
and i think you do a great job
explaining complicated science to lots
of people so
thank you for doing that thank you so
speaking of genome editing
um what was your introduction to genome
editing because i think most people when
they think of it nowadays they think
about christopher but obviously
christopher wasn't
the first genome editing technique that
was used
so what was your introduction to genome
editing
right so um you know as is often the
case
the the route that we
follow in science is a combination of
our curiosity
um but also a lot of serendipity and
uh and the network of chance meetings
and
and friends that you happen to have so
in our case our lab has always
uh since it started in 1999 uh
specialized in using
sort of the components of biological
evolution
including in vitro selection mutation
replication to address problems
in biology and in therapeutic science
at the time i had a graduate student
vikram patanayak
who was working on an in vitro selection
system that could identify
rnas with certain biological properties
and while he was sort of
thinking about what project he should do
next
he happened to attend a harvard medical
school event
he's a medical school student uh was a
medical school student
with uh and happened to sit next to
keith chung
now my good friend collaborator
colleague co-founder of a number of
companies
and simply by the good fortune that he
sat next to keith john
they ended up talking about an area that
keith
you know was really and continues to be
a leader in
namely zinc fingers and
what what vikram became interested in
and
confirmed with keith that that
this project idea was significant
was that zinc finger nucleases had
already started to enter the clinic
sangamo was running clinical trials on
ccr5 cleveland zinc finger nucleases
yet to our knowledge there was no
unbiased broad characterization of the
dna specificity of whole intact
zinc finger nucleuses what researchers
had done as a surrogate before was to
take
individual zinc finger arrays and do in
vitro selections
against libraries of dna to see what
they bound
but you could imagine as i think has
proven to be the case for many
dna binding proteins that the sequence
requirements for
nuclease cleavage are not exactly the
same as the sequence requirements for
dna binding
so this led to make a long story short
to a collaboration between our lab and
keys lab that was our very first
gene editing uh in fact it wasn't even
called gene editing then it was called
genome engineering
and then it became genome editing and
now it's called gene editing
but our very first project in that field
which was to
develop and apply an in vitro selection
method
that could very broadly characterize
the dna cutting specificity
of zinc finger nucleases in this broad
unbiased manner where
we took advantage of the fact that
you can make large libraries of circles
of
different dna sequences and when they're
cut they get linearized you can capture
the linear ends
it's actually related to some of the
current methods used to characterize the
off-target
dna cleavage activities of crispr
and talons and zinc fingernucleases and
indeed after publishing that first paper
on zinc fingernucleases with keith we
published a second on talons and a third
on cast nine which was a collaboration
with jennifer
doudna's lab our first with her lab um
and so our early foray into
uh into gene editing was really in
trying to achieve a deep understanding
of
their dna specificities of these agents
and how to improve them and in some
cases we were able to use the knowledge
we
gleaned from these unbiased specificity
profiling approaches
to improve the specificity of
of these programmable dna binding
domains
say so we started in other words by
simply trying to understand
these agents before we ended up
engineering and eventually creating our
own
cool yes i was gonna say i think you've
highlighted like so
when i was first introduced to these um
fingernail glasses
the major i guess the big problem with
it is trying to identify a way
of understanding the interaction of the
proteins with dna and how that
specificity is achieved as you mentioned
as by having that information you can
then in a way
kind of reprogram those nucleuses so
that they can recognize
other sites of interest and i say and so
that's kind of where
i guess crispr comes in and instead of
using a protein dna interaction
it uses an rna dna interaction which we
understand a lot better
in terms of being able to reprogram um
rna sequences
and so it gave much more control over
the specificity of targeting the editing
complex
and so when i first learned about crispr
um i think
i had like a kind of wow movement like i
definitely remember them the moment when
i read
um either the paper i watched jennifer
doudna talk about it on a ted talk i
think
yeah i was a bit late to learning about
christopher technologies and so i guess
what was do you remember how it felt
when you first learnt about crispr
yeah it was a kind of aha moment
you know i think the very first time i
started reading crispr papers
was uh after um
hearing about uh fun john's
one of funjon's talks or papers where
a colleague said hey um you know
you should really um check out this
this area it seems like it's it's
getting pretty interesting
uh and and you know i i remember having
a similar aha moment where
um you know we had been working quite a
bit with seeing finger nucleuses and
talons
by then um
and uh you know i think there's there's
no question that
the main barrier to zing finger
adoption as a more broadly used
biological tool
is that there is not really a simple
lookup table you can use to assemble
effective
sync finger arrays you can make
reasonable candidates that way but to
get them really
good you need to basically do a zing
finger library in vitro selection and a
lot of optimization
and to have a lot of know-how and there
are a handful of
of people in this world who can actually
do that um
and and then of course tail arrays uh i
think became
more popular quite quickly because they
were actually
more or less
de novo designable using the lookup
table that
various scientists including pogba novae
uncovered so
when it became when when crispr came on
the scene
and the lookup table was basically
watson creek based pairing
i think uh it did get get me
very excited that uh perhaps this was
the moment
that uh addressing the genome in this
digital programmable way uh would
would finally be realized uh not just
for a company or for
a handful of academics with specialized
expertise but
maybe for the general life sciences
so it was really exciting i think nobody
back then
could have predicted just how
democratized it would end up
becoming but uh but it you know was the
start of one of the great revolutions in
the life science it's something that
um you know does not come along very
frequently might come along once it once
a generation or so
i completely agree um and yeah i know
christopher has definitely
revolutionized as you say not only
potentially the way we can treat
different genetic diseases but also just
as a research tool
um like with christmas screens um so
investigate and understand
um how the cells are working but um like
with
crispr cast 9 the canonical system in
addition to seeing finger nucleuses
and talons what they the way that they
work is by inducing double-stranded
brakes
and so double-stranded brakes um are
quite deleterious for a cell it's it's a
major form of damage for a cell
and it's had race concerns in different
papers about
inducing the dna damage response in
terms of the p53 mediated response
and so there's concerns over not only um
basically the safety of having um
an editing machinery that induces a
double-stranded break and so that's led
to
um finding solutions that edit without
having a double-stranded break that
might be potentially safer
in case there was any off-target um
editing going on
and so um was that why you ended up
discovering uh base editing or how did
base editing come about
could you explain a bit about that yeah
it's a great question
um so as i think you just gave a
a great concise summary of of
double strand breaks and their role in
in gene editing
you know it really began with maria
jason's seminal discovery that a double
strand break
can stimulate increased rates of
homologous recombination
at the cut site and
because the the use of
the connection between double-stranded
breaks which is cutting a chromosome
into two pieces
and gene editing really began with
maria jason and others discovering the
relationship between double-stranded
breaks and homologous recombination
products
i think there was a great
hope early on in the gene editing
field's history that being able to to
make targeted double-stranded breaks
with these programmable nucleases
whether they're zinc fingernucleases or
talons or crispr cast-9
would provide a way to to do precise
gene correction
unfortunately uh we now know that
this process of homology directed repair
or hdr
as it's called uh which is the way that
a double-stranded break can be turned
into a precise edit
uh is is unfortunately not general and
uh virtually no therapeutically relevant
cell types
support uh hdr with an efficiency that
would be
considered useful uh for at least four
therapeutic applications
as a research tool it is widely used and
in vitro
under a variety of conditions you can
find cells that support hdr
but you know perhaps tellingly i think
when i checked uh last month
uh so february 2021
somebody asked me how many crispr
clinical trials are there right now and
the answer is so i looked it up there's
43 of them
how many of them are trying to use a
double-stranded break to induce precise
gene repair through homology directed
repair the answer is zero
all of the therapeutic trials uh using
crispr right now
um are using crispr to disrupt genes
because the branch of fate that happens
once you make a double-stranded cut in a
chromosome
is predominantly in most cell types to
to lead to gene disruption uh through
indel formation
meaning the cell is desperately trying
to get the ends of the broken chromosome
back together
and in the process it will uh
often get the ends together perfectly
but then the nuclease can just
chop up the uh the site again
and you you go back to the broken
chromosome so
every now and then the act of joining
the ends back together makes a mistake
and those mistakes slow down the process
of subsequent cutting so you
you see an accumulation of those dead
end products
collectively called indels because they
have insertions and deletions it's
mostly deletions it should be called
dell ends it's just more awkward to say
i suppose
um and so to be clear you know making
indels in a targeted gene
can be quite useful but you have to get
kind of lucky
if that is your therapeutic strategy
one really important example where
scientists where biology did provide
that luck
is sickle cell anemia beta thalassemia
some blood diseases
caused by homozygous mutations
in the adult hemoglobin gene called
beta-globin
you can compensate for those mutations
not by fixing directly the beta-globin
genes i mean you could do that in
principle that's just harder
to do it with the nucleus for the
reasons we just described
but instead you can use gene disruption
to fix
to rescue some of those diseases by
disrupting
a gene that is involved in the silencing
of fetal hemoglobin
so as i'm sure you know and and your
audience is probably
becoming increasingly familiar with uh
we're born with redundant sets of
hemoglobin genes
we have a fetal hemoglobin set of genes
that is responsible for most of our
hemoglobin when when we are gestating as
fetuses
and then around the time of birth it
begins to be silenced and adult
hemoglobin
gene expression begins to be turned on
instead
so researchers have identified many of
the genes involved in silencing that
fetal hemoglobin
and if you can disrupt those genes then
you can actually
disrupt those genes then you can
actually turn back on fetal hemoglobin
and uh almost everybody who has
defective beta-globin genes
has healthy fetal hemoglobin genes uh so
it's probably a reasonably strong
selection during embryogenesis
so so even if you if you lose the
genetic lottery
and you inherit or are born with two
defective adult beta globin genes you
can still
lead a normal life if you have mutations
that disrupt
silencing of fetal hemoglobin a very
lucky number of people a small very
lucky number of
well you could argue they're lucky and
unlucky uh we're born with
all of those mutations they have
mutations in their adult hemoglobin that
should give them
serious blood diseases but they also
have mutations in the genes that are
necessary to silence fetal hemoglobin so
they end up being okay
and so a bunch of really smart
scientists and companies
have exploited this observation to use
crispr cas9
or other double strand break inducing
programmable nucleases to disrupt
the the genes that silence fuel
hemoglobin
so that's an example of how gene
disruption can actually
benefit a patient but the reason i said
you have to get kind of lucky is
you know there are a number of small
miracles that all had to take place to
create this perfect storm of a situation
where gene disruption can rescue a
genetic disease
most of the time in order to benefit a
patient we need to fix
a mutation not simply disrupt it further
the mutation has already disrupted the
gene or
or created a version of the gene that
leads to health problems
and in most cases simply disrupting the
gene further
isn't expected to benefit patients
instead we need to
mediate precise gene correction instead
of gene disruption
so i think that's sort of a background
that um
you know i don't think is a any kind of
great new insight it's
it's been known in human genetics for a
long time that the nature of most
mutations is that they need to be
fixed or complemented rather than
further disrupted in order to rescue a
disease phenotype
but the story about how base editing
began
then uh took that background and
married it again with the serendipitous
um
prospective postdoc candidates
application this is alexis comore
now a professor at ucsd um
alexis uh was a prospective postdoc
interviewed in my group
um our lab was very impressed with her
uh i made her an offer and as i often do
with post talks even before they arrived
we began to exchange emails about
okay what what projects did you work on
so when they arrive they can hit the
ground running
and and so i asked her what are you
interested in doing and
and uh she uh emailed me a list of
of uh sort of proto project ideas
one of which i thought was was kind of
interesting
she was proposing the use of puff
proteins which are
programmable sort of programmable rna
binding proteins
to mediate changes to rna
and you know i told her i think this is
interesting but
what would potentially be particularly
transformative
i think i used fairly grandiose language
in my email to her which i've now
been asked to dig up several times by a
journalist
and i think this was back in 2013 so a
long time ago
2013 uh i i told her
if you can
develop a way to do chemistry directly
on a base pair
to change one base pair to another base
pair in dna
given the challenges that were beginning
to be understood
with homology directed repair and making
double stranded breaks
i think the wording i used was uh you
you could
you would transform the life sciences
and quite possibly medicine
or something like that um and so we
began to brainstorm
uh how to do this and um
uh you know she pointed out uh so we
quickly focused on
cited indiana aces
i think i had uh proposed that she look
at
some of the enzymes known to turn c's
into use and use of course pair like
teas
uh she raised to the i think very good
point that these daminases
seem to work on single-stranded dna and
of course most genomic dna is not single
stranded
and then as we thought about what
different dna binding proteins
to use uh i think in a subsequent email
i pointed out that
the the single stranded requirement of
most yaminases
uh doesn't bother me too much because
cas9 is known to unwind the dna
into single strands into single strands
and you know i think at the time that
sort of made logical sense but
uh i didn't fully appreciate how
enabling uh
that uh simple ability of cast nine to
create a single stranded
dna r-loop uh when it engages the target
dna sequence
was and you know as as a sort of
uh perfect storm of of uh
of molecular interactions you know cas9
because it has to pair the guide rna
in a watson creek style with one of the
target dna strands
it has to unwind the dna double helix so
that one strand can pair with the guide
rna
and that leaves the other strand as a
sort of free single stranded dna bubble
and it's within that single stranded
bubble that phase editing occurs on the
quote non-targeted strand
so the crispr biologist named the strand
that pairs with the guide rna as the
targeted
strand but for base editing it's
actually the other strand that gets
edited first
um so so uh so that was the basic idea
and we even in early on uh
talked about how we would probably have
to
impede the uracil dna glycosylase
enzymes
that otherwise are very highly evolved
to look for
uracil in dna and cut it out because
cytosine turns out to be the least
stable of the four dna bases
and you know your roughly one billion
cytosines in each of your cells undergo
spontaneous deamination
at a rate that results in several
hundred of them every day becoming
yourself
so that would probably be an
unacceptable level of mutation
uh were it not for the fact that your
cells and i think
just about every kind of cell has
evolved a
very efficient mechanisms to constantly
look for these uracils in dna and cut
them out
and then replace them with seeds
so so we identified a a small protein
inhibitor that would
shut down that process called uracil
glycosylase inhibitor
that we could localize to the side of
the base edit to try to block
uracil glycosylation at least
transiently at that site
and then the final piece came uh as an
insight that alexis had
uh following her discussions with other
group members
so at that time we had the cited in the
eminence piece the cast nine piece
the uh the years look glycosylase piece
and we were getting you know okay
amounts of base editing maybe
10 or 15 editing uh thanks to the ugi it
was reasonably clean
but we were trying to get the process to
be more efficient
and you know we speculated that the
ceiling of efficiency was probably
going to be fifty percent uh using that
architecture because if you create a ug
mispair
the cell has to figure out whether the u
is the correct information or the g
is the correct information and it's
going to resolve that disagreement
either in your favor
creating a ua base pair which is what
you want or it'll go back to the
starting material to create a cg
and uh and so we thought well maybe we
could and this is really the insight
that alexis
brought to my attention that she had a
hunch that if you nicked the g
containing strand that that would cue
mismatch repair
which in eukaryotic cells uses nics
to signify newly synthesized and
therefore less
validated dna that that the nick would
cue mismatch repair to replace
the segment containing the g with the
newly synthesized dna segment
and because there was a uracil on the
opposite side of the double helix
when it was re-synthesizing that that
new dna segment it would put in an a
opposite the u and that would complete
the conversion of the information on
both strands
uh to what you know from what used to be
a cg base pair now to a ua or a ta base
pair
and so that adding that simple nick
which required just
a single mutation put back into
uh into our be2 base editor
resulted in ve3 which was the first you
know reasonably efficient cytosine base
editor
and and we showed that it was now able
to
think in our original paper you know
edit 30 or 40 percent sometimes
70 but clearly showing you could you
could actually exceed 50
editing by biasing that
mismatched repair process which would
otherwise to a first approximation
be a coin toss to instead favor the
repair of both dna strands the way you
wanted
and now of course base editors have been
improved by many labs
including our own over many generations
and
you know we've in some recent
experiments that multiple people in the
lab have done at multiple different
target sites for multiple
uh genetic diseases they get close to
100 editing
so it's really come a long way and you
know there were uh
in fact a new first year graduate
student named lily in the lab has
achieved 100
editing at multiple target sites
in including in patient-derived
inpatient fibroblasts primary
fibroblasts so
uh so based on has come a long way and
and there were moments
early on even right when we published
the paper in 2016
where we wondered are we ever going to
be able to achieve you know
80 90 100 editing even though i think
for the vast majority of genetic
diseases
to benefit patients you don't need
editing that efficient
but the answer actually is yes you can
get close to 100
base editing using the variety of
improvements that the community
uh have now advanced from our original
work in 2016. and i should also mention
that
uh two groups in japan uh professors
nishida and kondo working together
reported in science uh several months
after our initial base editor paper that
alexis led uh reported in science a
similar system where they used a
different deaminase
but also with cas9 also nicking the
opposite strand
and reported similar results so that was
also welcome news because it really
showed that
that you know independent groups were
were finding the same
uh outcomes that you could now make for
the first time
targeted single base pair changes
without cutting
the dna double helix without cutting a
chromosome into pieces
uh in a living mammalian cell in a
living human cell
and that really of course got us uh
fixated on
okay let's figure out how to how to fix
as many possible types of mutations
that are responsible for genetic disease
and that researchers might want to
install in cells to study
the properties of genes as possible but
the boundary conditions are you can't
make double stranded breaks
well no that's really incredible to hear
the the backstory to how
base editing started and it's incredible
also to hear that you're approaching 100
efficiency um
which is definitely um pretty amazing
considering
um like where it started with um and say
obviously
you've now taken um base editing to beam
therapeutics which uk founded
and you're trying to now take um
the the basic science and discovery and
taking it to being able to treat
different genetic diseases
and so um out of the different genetic
diseases what um
what do you think base editing will be
used for fast in terms of getting to
patients in the clinic yeah well so beam
has disclosed a variety of
of programs that they plan to bring to
the clinic
uh this year or shortly there afterwards
and uh based on their announcements uh
they've
disclosed that they are they have
developed base editing strategies to
treat
uh some blood diseases uh they've
developed base editing to base editing
strategies to
treat some metabolic diseases as well
like
alfie alpha-1 anti-trypsin
deficiency
and i think they've also disclosed that
they have uh
been able to base at it to correct some
genetic alleles that are involved in
uh some blindness diseases as well
uh i i
always want to make sure that uh
anything i'm sharing is something that
they've already shared so
uh uh just point people to the beam
therapeutics website where they
i think list the programs that they've
publicly disclosed
but i think maybe from from a more meta
perspective
you know a decision that i admire that
that beam
has made is they recognize that the
platform
was so broad in its potential
applicability to diseases that they
would not focus on just one
organ one type of disease one delivery
modality
but instead beam has i think done a
great job
trying to advance as many programs as
possible to cover
the broadest possible range of of
diseases and therefore of patients that
could benefit from
base editing technology and so they have
really chosen to to pursue
as many programs that meet you know some
key criteria like
is there bulletproof biology that
relates the correction of the mutation
to the correction of the disease
uh is there a delivery modality that can
uh
that is promising to deliver the base
editors to
the cells that are anticipated to lead
to
disease rescue if corrected
and uh you know what are the
uh uh what are the potential base
editing strategies
that can fix the mutation with the best
current based editing technologies known
and you know fortunately i think is a
sign of of the progress that has led to
literally hundreds of base editors now
being published
uh having been published um uh
that third criteria is increasingly
proving easier
and easier to meet that with all of the
different kas9 pam variants
the different cast proteins that have
proven to be compatible with pace
editors including a variety of cast 12
variants um uh
that uh targeting is is
increasingly uh uh not an issue
and uh and even sort of positioning the
target nucleotide
with respect to the base editing window
has also been simplified not just by the
fact that there are now
lots of different pamp sequences that
you can target that is lots of places in
the genome where you can
park a base editor but researchers have
started to have some
success controlling where the base
editing window is and how wide or how
narrow it is
and so that diversity of literally
hundreds of base editors that are
available now
greatly increase the chance that if you
have a
mutation you're trying to correct uh you
can do so with
uh with a base editor without too much
trouble well then
that's super exciting because yeah
that's what i'm um obviously the
concerns for base editing as you
obviously have cast 9 coming into the
dna site
opening up the dna region and obviously
in theory there could be
potential for off target editing of
different sites so having control over
that window is
a great advance right and
and uh researchers have shown that you
can both
mutate the deaminases to control that
window and you can also mutate the cast
9
and in in maybe intellectually at least
my favorite
solution you can circularly permute cas9
proteins
something that dave savage has had
success with and so we collaborated with
with his lab and showed that these
circularly permuted
cast nines do indeed change enough the
topology of the r loop relative to the
diaminase that you can
uh move uh in some cases broaden in
other cases actually
move over uh the base editing window
um so uh so having a
sort of bookshelf with lots and lots of
different books that each have slightly
different properties
has proven to be especially useful for
enabling base editing to
serve as many purposes as possible it is
at as many target sites as
as pos as possible with as many
performance characteristics as is needed
to
enable the research or the therapeutic
application of interest
wow that's super exciting um and so
obviously
the debate editing has given us a
massive toolkit then
but in terms of the actual editing it's
still obviously any
um a base editing even with multiplexing
it's just editing
a specific basis and so obviously in
terms of precision genome editing
there's still the kind of search for
being able to make larger scale
dynamic changes that we have control
over instead of forming indels
and so um i think that kind of nicely
leads on to prime
editing and what prime editing is and
how
what kind of challenges it was trying to
solve right
yeah so um to to fill in that that story
i think it's a great segue
um so the the alexis comore led
uh cytosine base editor can only make
two kinds of dna changes it can change
c's into ts and g's into a's
and so our first effort to really
broaden the applicability of
precise gene genome editing without
double stranded breaks
was to develop a different kind of base
editor an adenine based editor
which can change a's into g's and t's
into c's
so it actually does the opposite of what
a cytosine base editor does
uh that just by because of the nature of
human
gene mutations that adenine base editor
turns out to be
the most useful kind of single base pair
corrector if your goal is to correct
mutations that are responsible for
pathogenic
changes in cells for diseases so about
half of
pathogenic disease point mutations are
caused
by the kind of base pair change that is
fixed with an adenine base editor
and so on so nicole godelli a former
postdoc in the lab now at beam
therapeutics developed this adenine base
editor that
changes at base pairs to gc base pairs
and there the project was um you know i
give her a lot of credit because
uh the the key enzyme to deaminate
adenine in dna
wasn't known there there was no known
and there still is no known naturally
occurring
reported enzyme that will deaminate
adenine into scene in dna and so nicole
agreed to take the brave step of
evolving her own enzyme
as the starting material for this
project uh even though in general in our
lab we
we stay away from projects where step
one is evolve
a starting material because it sort of
sounds like two
significant projects not one um
and so after a lot of hard work she she
did
manage to evolve the first enzyme to our
knowledge
that can deaminate adenine in dna and
convert it into a base
that pairs like g
and then we could install that new
deaminase that nicole evolved into a
base editing architecture and then that
led to the adenine base editor
and then we've further evolved it which
led to these
uh super active variants like abe8e
and that's the variant that we and
others are now seeing
consistently uh at some sites in certain
kinds of cells
um uh you know more than 90 editing
but but even with the cytosine based
editors that alexis developed and the
adenine base editor is then a cold
developed
that's only four kinds of face-to-base
changes
and of course simple math will tell you
because there's four different dna
letters
and you can change each letter to three
other kinds that means there's 12
total ways you can mutate one base to
another base so the eight remaining
mutations which are called transversions
we could not make with base editing at
least not
not efficiently and directly
and of course there are a large number
of
insertions and deletions uh the vast
majority of which are small
fewer than 10 or 20 bases that are
associated with
really important genetic diseases like
cystic fibrosis
and taste sex disease
so uh so it's been a i think a
long standing goal of the group since we
started working with base editors to
figure out
a way to directly install those other
kinds of base to base changes
and to install deletions or insertions
again without making double-stranded
breaks and that led to the development
of
of prime editing which can achieve those
goals in
a million cells so prime editing really
began also with a prospective group
member
uh a prospective postdoc named andrew
anzalone
who applied to the lab um he's a former
md phd student at columbia he worked
with virginia cornish
um who was a former lab mate of mine
when i was a
grad student in peter schultz's lab
virginia was a postdoc in the lab
anyhow virginia recommended andrew
strongly and
and when he came to the lab at the end
of his meetings with various people
um you know i have a one-on-one meeting
with him right before he gives his
group meeting talk and i asked him the
usual questions
um you know what other labs are you
interested in
uh what kinds of projects do you
envision
working on what's the time frame of your
desired postdoc et cetera and when i
asked him
what do you think you're working on he
pulled out
this um kind of audacious idea
uh that that he had written up into a
slide basically
uh which uh proposed that
perhaps we could use
a reverse transcriptase to directly copy
this an edited dna sequence from
the extent from an extension on a guide
rna
into a nicked target dna site and
you know it was a wild idea and there
were all sorts of reasons why
it might have failed um it really took
a confluence of you know what at the
time we called small miracles but now i
think just
uh to be to be more accurate but
was just a reflection of the hard work
of andrew and co-workers to overcome
but i was excited enough by the idea
that
i asked him to do something i normally
don't ask prospective postdocs to do
which is why don't you present that idea
at the end of your your postdoc seminar
so he gave his group meeting seminar
about his phd work and at the end he
put in a slide on his idea
and you know as you might imagine the
the lab found it really interesting but
was also very skeptical about
all sorts of various pieces of it
including the fact that
when you nick dna and you put on
edited dna you have to figure out the
cells to figure out what to do with that
edited dna flap which is now redundant
with the non-edited sequence that's
still
on the dna double helix ahead of that
nick
and even if that edited dna flap somehow
somehow
ends up sitting down on dna you now have
a heteroduplex where one strand is
edited one strand is not edited but the
edited strand the one you care about was
recently nick
so isn't that going to be preferentially
removed by mismatch repair
et cetera the answer to all those
questions actually turns out to be
yes but uh it still works
um so to make a long story short andrew
started in a test tube where we like to
start out since
we're our group has uh
has is historically made of chemists and
we have strong
chemistry ties so we like to start out
in a test tube where we can control and
analyze things easier
his idea seems to be plausible in a test
tube in a test tube you showed that
a cast 9 knick case plus a reverse
transcriptase
um plus a guide rna with
a reverse transcriptase template added
to its three prime or five prime end
could template reverse transcription of
the nicked target dna site and we ran
all the proper controls to show that
these weren't artifacts and then he
tried this in yeast cells
and it worked quite well in yeast
which was starting to get interesting
however yeast
are addicted to all sorts of dna repair
processes that
are very difficult to do in humans such
as
homologous recombination which is really
easy to do in yeast
but very difficult to do in humans in
fact yeast prefer to make
homologous recombination products over
indels in many
in many cases in response to
double-stranded breaks whereas the
opposite is true in human cells
so um so so we were sort of cautiously
starting to get excited but we really
didn't know
um know if it would work in in mammalian
cells and so then he
started trying mammalian cells and his
first experiments were all complete
failures
zero percent editing not even 0.5
percent editing
and and you know andrew very quickly
figured out what changes in the system
were needed
to get it to work in mammalian cells and
then i remember in one monday
subgroup meeting people walk into my
office every monday we
everybody in the lab presents in
alternate mondays so everyone presents
every other week
uh what what they've been up to what
problems they've encountered
what uh results it's positive or
negative
uh they've garnered over the past couple
weeks and
uh the lab helps brainstorm ideas for
what to do next how to fix
problems et cetera and as we were
walking in
as the students were walking into my
office that monday
one of the students looked at me as he
walked by and said you are going to
freak out
which is usually a good a good thing to
hear before one of these meetings
uh and and you know i said oh
why and he said because andrew has data
mammalian cells
and so andrew presented the first prime
editing data in mammalian cells and
you know it was very modest it was a few
percent editing
but the fact that we could now install
transversions and insertions and
deletions for the first time
at targeted sites in mammalian cells was
uh was electrifying and uh and
uh just caused a sort of buzz in the
group
and an excitement and all sorts of
brainstorming about what to do next
uh that was you know probably unlike
anything i've seen in the 22 years i've
been a professor
sure i i bet it does i'm and in
particular i think the most remarkable
thing about the prime editing design
is the fact that you extended the guide
rna and so
the guide rna not only contains the
primary site for the refrigerator
transcriptase but it also contained the
desired edit changes
and so what that meant is you didn't
need to introduce a
donor template that had the side edit
and so in many ways you kind of
simplified the system as well
right and uh you know one of the several
things that
had to work out in order for it to be
successful is
so as you point out there's a primary
binding site that has to complement the
nicked dna strand so that
it aligns the nicked dna strand here
so this part is that i use my youtube
uh use my my zoom here so this part is
the primer binding site
here's the nick dna strand and then the
rest of my right hand
is the reverse transcriptase template
and so this structure has to align and
reverse transcription then goes in this
direction to copy the edited dna
sequence directly into the target
dna strand of the mammalian of the human
cell genome
however this primer binding site here
therefore mathematically must complement
the spacer part of the guide rna the
guide rna still has to do
its main job of programming
the crispr protein to engage the target
dna site
and so the primer binding site is
complementary to
the spacer which means maybe all that a
peg rna a prime editing guide rna would
end up doing is forming
a sort of stem loop um so that was
you know one of the the risks and
and indeed we found that you have to be
very careful how long that primer
binding site is
you make it too long even though
normally polymerases
love having lawn primer binding sites
because it provides a bigger runway to
more stable runway to initiate dna
polymerization
in this case prime editing is all about
walking
the line between a variety of boundary
conditions and threading that needle so
that
you can initiate these molecular events
without
going uh without forming structures that
and
would ultimately be non-productive so
the primer binding site has to be
of a moderate length long enough to
support reverse transcription but not so
long that it ends up impeding the spacer
anyhow so all of that ended up actually
working out and
after some improvements and a lot of
testing
in lots of different
gene sites and in different cell types
we reported prime editing at the end of
of 2019 and it's been subsequently and
then of course shortly thereafter
everything shut down because of the
pandemic
but our lab and others have continued to
use
and advance prime editing and now there
have been a number of improvements
some of which have been published by
other labs others of which
we hope to report this year
that following in the footsteps of base
editing that have advanced prime editing
towards
broader and broader applicability and
greater and greater efficiency
and you know one thing that i think the
roughly 30 or so prime editing
papers or preprints that have already
been published
seem to point to is the dna specificity
of prime editing really does appear to
be
very high higher than that of
traditional crispr
gene editing platforms
because probably the in order for the
prime edit to actually take place
watson creek based pairing has to occur
not just between the spacer and the
protospacer
the spacer of the guide rna and the
protospace or the target side of the dna
but also of the primer binding site and
the nicked dna
strand and then downstream between the
three prime flap
and the original dna strand so there's
three different checks
on dna hybridization on sequence
fidelity
that each server is an opportunity to
reject an off-target sequence
and we think that's why prime editing is
has now been uh observed in multiple
labs to be
uh extremely dna sequence specific this
has definitely an
added benefit then right um and as well
i'm
at least in the original prime medicine
paper to as you said with base editing
one of the problems is you end up with a
mismatch right where one strand's got
the edit and the other one doesn't and
so you want to kind of bias
the cell to choose the strand of the
desired edits and the way that you did
that was by having a secondary
uh cast 9 complex that introduced the
nick like a bit downstream
and so have you find ways um obviously
the concern with that is that you've now
got a nick
in two places which could cause um a
staggered double stranded break which is
something that you would maybe kind of
want to avoid
and so have you found ways of
circumventing that um would that
be an issue in terms of being able to
translate prime editing to the clinic
yeah so if you nick that bottom strand
you do
increase energy and efficiencies but you
also increase intel levels
intel levels are generally with that
doubly nicked
version of the prime editing system are
generally higher than that of base
editing but
with still favorable ratios of editing
to in bells
so it might be for example you get 30
prime editing and
you know eight percent in dells or
something like that
so we have uh improved that aspect of it
in a in a couple ways which we hope to
report this year
uh one is we have identified um
some of the uh the proteins that are
implicated
that are involved in the prime editing
intermediate advancing and resolution
and have manipulated those proteins to
favor the desired outcome
and that tends to increase
primating efficiencies uh in many cases
to the point that you don't need the
bottom
strand nick anymore to get sort of
therapeutically relevant levels of prime
editing
even in some therapeutically relevant
cell types
like t cells or or primary patients
certain kinds of primary patient cells
also we have uh developed
variants of i'd say you how to use the
we've become better at how to use the
prime editing system
to program that second nick
so that it only occurs after the first
strand has been repaired which minimizes
the coincidence of having two nicks
and then finally we've also gotten
better at
choosing where to nick where to put that
second nick
so that it minimizes the chance of that
the tunics turn into a double stranded
break nicks occur all over your genome
quite frequently it's estimated that
you know at any moment there might be
hundreds if not thousands of mix in your
genome
so the the trick to avoid turning nicks
into double-stranded brakes if they're
on opposite strands
is to make sure that the knicks either
never occur at the same time
or if they do occur at the same time
they're far enough away that there's
plenty of watts and great base pairs to
hold the double helix together
um and and to avoid having the ends come
apart into a double-stranded break
so it's a it's a great question and uh
there
are i think a number of approaches that
some published some
not yet reported uh that improve that
aspect of prime editing
cool i i think one of the things that
fascinates me most about
just the crispr cast 9 system is the
number of ways that you can kind of
modify it so as you've mentioned you can
modify not only the cat9 protein itself
by
mutating it you can also modify the
guide rna as
demonstrated with prime editing and so i
guess
um somewhat um i'm
my um one of the major reasons why i'm
interested in it is during my master's
project
i was actually working on something very
similar whereby i was also trying to
um perform precise genome editing by
having only a single stranded break so
instead of a double stranded break
and um my approach was slightly
different and unfolds
um fusing cas9 to just a variety of
different um
protein domains and seeing what would
work obviously um
i mean that work i don't think would
ever get published now because i mean
you've got prime editing
um but it was interesting you should you
should probably should you should
publish it i think it's still
interesting in fact we had a
vaguely similar project where holly
reese in my lab
fused uh found that using a cas9 knit
case to a rad 51
protein could in increase the efficiency
of single strand
nic directed hdr in certain
circumstances
um but you know i think all of these
tools
and all of the insights that come from
their development contribute to the
field so i think you should uh
publish that work maybe we should talk
about us um
encourage your api to enhance it
but yeah i think um the one thing that i
did with my project
um is i came up with an alternative name
for it
so the name that i went for was cas9 she
which i thought was quite catchy so
that's
s-h-e-e and it stood for
safe and high-efficiency editing which
is i guess the kind of
the tea problems we're trying to solve
with um genome editing
and then there was a kind of catch
phrase that went along with it which was
cast nine she is key for genome editing
um
in my slides to see if anyone got it but
um yeah i had a bit of fun with that
um
yeah science needs more puns it's true
um so going um one thing i haven't
spoken about yet which i'm quite
interested in
is a big problem with genome editing
besides safety besides efficiency
is actually being able to deliver these
complexes into the side cells
and so there are obviously x fever
approaches
but um i think that the major challenges
at the moment are more with
in fever approaches so you're getting
them into human patients
and so at least from my understanding
there are two main ways in which this
can be done
the first one is by using um
adeno-associated viruses
and the second one using lipid
nanoparticles
and so i was wondering if you could talk
about both of those what you think is
more promising will it vary
um which ones use depending on the
genetic disease
right i think just like the editing
agents themselves the delivery
modalities
uh you know we will need and eventually
use a whole
library of different ones there are
an endless variety of of lipid
nanoparticles that have been shown
to deliver to various organs in vivo
they can deliver messenger rna they can
deliver
dna they can deliver the
the rnp the protein rna complex
and some have been used with remarkable
results verve therapeutics
in collaboration with beam reported the
use of lmps to deliver
rnas encoding base editors into primates
to base edit pcsk9
to to cause uh a drop
in pcsk9 protein levels that result in
lowering of
serum ldl cholesterol and triglyceride
levels which of course are
strong correlates of cardiovascular
disease
[Music]
and you know on the aav side uh
our lab reported recently the use of aav
uh injected into the bloodstream of a
mouse with
the human progeria gene
to directly base at it so the aav
encodes a base editor
uh the base editor corrects the mutation
that causes progeria and people
and and in mice and and rescues
uh quite strongly many of the phenotypic
manifestations of progeria that are seen
in these mice
some of which uh parallel
uh the consequences of progeria in human
patients
so those are examples but i think going
forward
there are now hundreds of aav variants
that researchers have
reported that have all sorts of
different tissue tropisms and other
different properties
there are dozens if not hundreds of
lipid nanoparticles that researchers
have reported
that likewise have different
biodistribution properties
different half-lives different delivery
efficiencies
and so i think even just those two
modalities
will likely play a fairly important role
going forward and an increasingly
diversified role
being able to deliver these
macromolecular machines
to or the nucleic acids that encode them
to a variety of of targeted tissues
cool um and so um the other questions
that i want to do is kind of taking a
bit of a sidestep
is the fact that on this channel a lot
we talk i talk about
um targeting aging and finding ways to
target aging and effectively
age-associated diseases and um
there's a lot of work being conducted at
the moment in terms of looking at
epigenetic marks and its association
with aging and so i was just wondering
what are your
current opinions on the potential for
precise
epi genome editing by using maybe crispr
castline approaches
for example instead of having um the
cast iron fused to
a adenine based editor you instead have
um
a d-methylase enzyme or an acetate
enzyme or something completely different
right and and researchers have done
exactly what you've just described and
there are
um multiple systems now including one
uh just reported or being about to be
reported by
jonathan weissman and and the gilbert
and their their co-workers i think
jonathan's given a bunch of talks
on the topic so i suspect he wouldn't
mind uh me talking about it
uh but uh the weissman system is called
crisper off
and it uses uh
it uses a cutting incompetent cast nine
like we use in our base editors a dead
cast nine
fused to a variety of very uh carefully
and and cleverly chosen proteins
to programmably turn off a whole region
of
of dna and it does so in a in a
heritable way in a way that's durable
which is really quite cool so it's not
as though you
necessarily have to administer for the
rest of the lifetime of the organism or
the patient uh the the editing agents
to get a long-lasting change in gene
expression
but i i generally agree that uh that
um you know targeted epigenetic
modulation
is one of the uh the great frontiers of
of this new uh kind of democratized
programmable way of looking at the
genome
and in the interest of full disclosure
uh i
uh i have co-founded a company in this
space
called chroma medicine with jonathan
weissman
uh keith john and andrew gilbert so
to be transparent uh i i certainly
believe enough in
in the potential of of those systems uh
to be involved in trying to translate
that into
patient benefit cool and you mentioned
one question i was going to ask you
about which is the heritability of the
fact that
obviously with genome editing it kind of
makes sense right if you've managed to
edit
the genetic dna sequence it can get
passed on
through the semi-conservative
replication to next cells but epi
um genetic changes i just say it can be
questionable about whether or not they
would be permanent
but um i think our understanding of um
the epigenetic is improving all the time
and um cell states which pretty much
governs which genes are being expressed
in different cell types
and cellular reprogramming going from a
differentiated cell back to a stem cell
um are all things that essentially could
be mediated by just making
maybe a few precise effigy name marks
that could propagate
throughout the rest of the cell i don't
know what your thoughts are right
now i totally agree and i i think one of
the
um one of the really cool scientific
discoveries
of the past few decades in my opinion
have been
has been the discovery of ways that
epigenetic marks
are maintained over time so that
changes to the state of
dna modification or proteins that
regulate gene expression
are not simply modulating gene
expression
only at the moment that they're
installed
but rather they can actually be passed
down to progeny cells as well
so i mean in a sense it's it's the core
definition of epigenetics that
you can regulate
changes in biology even that are
heritable
that don't necessarily require changes
in dna
and that that phenomenon is is both
is both now pretty well established is
highly relevant for treating
potentially genetic diseases as well as
doing a lot of cool
research in biology and genetics
and i think is poised to be one of the
uh the great new frontiers of
of the sort of programmable taking
control of our genomes
space cool so you kind of
led on to my next question which is in
like 10 years time what kind of um
big offense or do you hope what are you
excited for in the next 10 years in
terms of
scientific breakthroughs that's a big
question but
yeah um i mean you know i hope within 10
years
we will see many of the technologies if
not all of the technologies
we've touched on during this interview
uh benefit patients and at the
at the rate of progress which shows no
signs of slowing down and only signs of
of speeding up i think it's easy to
predict that
i mean it's it's you know only been
uh what nine years since the very first
paper that reported
jennifer doudna martin jennings emmanuel
charpentier's paper reporting the use of
cas9 for genome editing
and it's only been uh five years since
our first base editing paper and only
been a year and a half since our first
prime editing paper
but these tools are very very widely
used
and advanced and companies have already
been founded to take all of these
technologies to the clinic to benefit
patients
in the case of the nucleases as i
mentioned they're already in people
there are already humans walking this
earth who
are experiencing for the first time a
relief of some of their symptoms of a
genetic disease because they have
crispr edited dna inside their body
edited xvivo first and then transplanted
but
there are also people who are in
clinical trials now who have had the
first in vivo
crispr editing take place uh in the body
and clinical trial that editors run for
example
so uh you know i think it's easy to
predict that within 10 years
uh there should not only be many many
more such trials but there should be
some
actual drugs on the market that
are benefiting patients uh suffering
from i think a
fairly wide range of diseases with a
genetic component
you know i'd be surprised and
disappointed if 10 years from now that
weren't the case
and you know hopefully
programmable epigenetic modulators will
begin to
be clinically used as well
by then um yeah
so i i you know with the caveat that i
think academics end up being
pre-selected to be optimists
because if you don't believe uh all this
stuff is going to work eventually and
then what's the point
um but you know i think 10 years is a
plausible time frame to see
most or all of these technologies
benefit patients in a very direct way
cool so that's super exciting so thank
you very much for taking the time to
talk to me today um i'm very excited to
hear about um
your work in the coming years and i
really hope that next time we'll be able
to talk in person
as opposed to through soon um but yeah
it was a pleasure
yeah likewise i would enjoy that i
really hope you keep doing these
um these interviews i think you're an
outstanding interviewer and and you have
a really
broad and and uh sophisticated
perspective on science
and i hope your readers
your and your following continue to
appreciate uh the work that you're doing
so please
keep up the important communication of
science
that that you've taken up
thank you so thank you for making it to
the end of this interview i hope you
enjoyed it
and i hope to continue doing them in the
future as i had some fun with it
so as always i hope you've learned
something in this video thank you to my
patreon supporters and thank you for
listening